[Applause]
i think it's fair to say that things are
a lot better
between william and harry we'll meet in
the middle okay
i can tell you that there were phone
calls and
video calls over the christmas and new
year holiday
and the sussexes sent presents to the
cambridges
and vice versa it was an opportunity in
an otherwise very busy
um and chaotic year for for both of the
families to come together and
connect albeit virtually if you go back
a year
at that stage these brothers were barely
on talking terms when william went
to the sandringham summit he was so
angry with his brother he couldn't even
face going for that lunch with the queen
he he only went for the meetings such
was his frustration
and and feeling of disappointment about
what his brother had done and how harry
was handling the situation
fast forward to today the relationship
is
much better than it was for a start they
are on talking terms and not only on
talking terms they they do speak
relatively regularly you know they were
very much in touch over the holidays but
there is an ocean between them there is
a time difference
um and as harry said in that interview
they are two brothers on different paths
we're brothers we will always be
brothers
and we're certainly on different paths
at the moment but i will always be there
for him and as i know he'll always be
there for me
we are watching them now take those
different paths but
i think there's a great sense of relief
um certainly within the royal family
that relations between the brothers are
much better
than what they were whether it will ever
be as close to relationship as it once
was
that's questionable but for sure it's
much better now
than it has been and it's not just
william that harry is in touch with he's
in touch with hit with his father the
prince of wales
and actually in quite regular contact
with the queen and
she is always delighted to see archie on
video calls
and it's very important to her that she
touches base with harry
she's in touch with them she she knows
what's going on in their lives
they discuss their plans with her harry
has always seen his grandmother as a
mentor and while he might be
in la that hasn't changed i think
possibly there was a time when harry may
have felt
a little bit homesick i think he was
missing home when his father
and his brother were ill with covid last
spring but i think
he he is loving the california west
coast lifestyle
it suits him he's always been a very
laid-back person
he loves nature he loves being by the
ocean so
i i hear that he is very very happy